sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren dies ist mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit die letzte sitzung
des deutschen bundestages in dieser
legislaturperiode und gerade in den
letzten tagen haben wir jetzt mit sehr
dramatischen problemen zu tun eben ist
das thema afghanistan hier genannt
wurden ich will die gelegenheit nutzen
da wir ja nach der letzten ausführlichen
debatte noch nicht die möglichkeit
hatten unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
die dort an dieser schwierigen
evakuierungs mission beteiligt waren ein
ganz herzliches dankeschön zu sagen das
war einer der schwierigsten einsätze
und da ist in der tat nicht gelungen ist
insbesondere im bereich der
entwicklungspolitik alle
schutzbedürftigen personen zu evakuieren
war es richtig dass der
bundesaußenminister auf eine reise
gegangen ist in die nachbarstaaten um
diese probleme zu besprechen wie wir aus
reisen auch in zukunft möglich machen
und unserer verantwortung nachkommen und
genauso war es richtig mit den
nachbarstaaten darüber zu reden wie wir
humanitäre probleme dort zu lösen helfen
genauso wie wir uns um die humanitäre
lage in afghanistan ganz besonders im
blick auf hunger und medizinische
versorgung weiter kümmern werden
ansonsten haben wir eine ausführliche
diskussion ja vor 14 tagen geführt und
was die sorgen im innenpolitischen
bereich anbelangt so hat das
insbesondere mit der furchtbaren
flutkatastrophe zu tun ich war in der
vergangenen woche am freitag und am
sonntag noch einmal in den flutgebieten
und darf nur sagen es richtig und
wichtig dass wir heute den hilfe hilfe
folgen in höhe von 30 milliarden euro
verabschieden und ich habe den menschen
zugesagt und ich denke das kann ich wird
hier von allen geteilt wir werden die
menschen die von dieser schrecklichen
furchtbaren flut betroffen sind nicht
vergessen der wiederaufbau wird jahre
monate jahre dauern und deshalb auch in
den
und das habe ihm zugesagt
und dieses flutkatastrophe hat natürlich
als extremwetterereignisse den fokus
noch einmal auf eines der drängendsten
themen unserer zeit geworfen nämlich auf
den kampf gegen den klimawandel und
deshalb sich an dieser stelle noch
einmal darauf hinweisen dass wir
wichtige weichen gestellt haben in
dieser legislaturperiode als die
bundeskanzlerin wohl im jahr 2005 taten
der zehn prozent der erzeugung von
energie aus für den strom aus
erneuerbaren energien heute liegen wir
deutlich über 40
aber viel wichtiger sind die
systemischen dinge die wir in dieser
legislaturperiode in angriff genommen
werden und haben und auf die wir auch
zukünftige regierungen aufbauen können
das klimaschutzgesetz mit jährlichen
budgets und sektor zählen ist ein
expertenrat und das sind nach steuerungs
pflichten also ein instrumentarium mit
dem wir wirklich bindende möglichkeiten
in der hand haben
zweitens haben wir die bepreisung von
co2 eingeführt ein marktwirtschaftliches
instrument mit dem der auf die reduktion
von co2 viel besser reagieren können wir
haben inzwischen eine millionen
elektroautos wir haben den ausstieg aus
der braunkohle miteinander vereinbart im
übrigen im gesellschaftlichen konsens
eine ganz wichtige sache sein
klimaschutz kann nur dann gelingen denn
die menschen im lande auch mitgenommen
werden und das war immer der ansatz der
großen koalition und das war auch
richtig so
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir alle
spüren ja und in den letzten jahren hat
das aus meiner sicht zugenommen dass die
welt eine welt in unruhe und im umbruch
ist und das völlig neue
herausforderungen uns beschäftigen und
natürlich auch deutschland beschäftigen
das ist terrorismus das ist cyber
kriminalität dass es die technologische
revolution der digitalisierung das ist
die ökonomische stärke von china neben
dem klimawandel ist es vor allen dingen
die digitalisierung die unser leben
vollkommen verändert
und wir haben uns in dieser großen
koalition immer vorgenommen möglichst
viele menschen so wie es eben beim
klimawandel gesagt habe mitzunehmen auf
die sind bei diesem wandel und deshalb
war ein zentrales thema unserer arbeit
in den letzten jahren die
gleichwertigkeit der lebensverhältnisse
in ganz deutschland zu sichern und zwar
zwischen ost und west zwischen stadt und
land eine vielzahl der maßnahmen der
bundesregierung hat sich genau mit
diesem thema
beschäftigt ich kann hier nur
stichpunkte nennen behörden
verlagerungen insbesondere in die neuen
bundesländer stärkung der ländlichen
räume das thema wohnen in
ballungsgebieten mit regulierung neubau
von wohnungen neu bau von
sozialwohnungen das wohneigentum für
familien wir haben eine ehrenamts
stiftung gegründet um das ehrenamt in
unserem land zu stärken und wir haben ja
gesehen welche bedeutung dieses ehrenamt
jetzt gerade in den großen
herausforderungen wie der
flutkatastrophe oder der pandemie und
wir haben die kommunen gestärkt
insbesondere auch durch übernahme von
kdu kosten von kosten der unterkunft für
die kommunen ein ganz wesentlicher punkt
um politik überhaupt lebbar zu machen
wir haben den rechtsstaat gestärkt durch
einen einzigartigen aufbau von mehr
personal und mehr möglichkeiten und wir
haben den kampf gegen den extremismus
insbesondere den rechtsextremismus
durchgeführt und bei den großen thema
digitalisierung haben wir entscheidende
fortschritte erzielt will daran erinnern
dass wir inzwischen behördengänge dass
wir inzwischen verwaltungsleistungen
digital anbieten insbesondere die des
bundes wir haben den die infrastruktur
ausgebaut breitbandanschlüsse mehr als
50 megabit pro sekunde waren am anfang
dieser legislaturperiode 80 prozent
jetzt sind es 94 prozent wir haben eine
verfügbarkeit von lte anschlüssen
mobilfunk von über 99 prozent das sind
dinge die kann man benennen es gibt
kleine schwierigkeiten nach wie vor an
vielen stellen flecken und ähnlich ist
aber meine damen und herren im großen
ganzen haben wir deutliche fortschritte
gemacht und das war richtig so
mit dem digital buck schule haben wir
mit den ländern gemeinsam 6,5 milliarden
euro investiert wir müssen jetzt
umgesetzt werden wir haben für digitale
innovationen 13,5 milliarden euro
eingesetzt und ich will noch einmal
darauf hinweisen die öffentlichen
investitionen haben sich seit im jahre
2005 genau verdoppelt das heißt also ein
schwerpunkt liegt bei den investitionen
und ein zentraler punkt das ist liegt
der schwerpunkt auf wissenschaft und
forschung das ist die quelle unseres
wohlstands für die zukunft und deshalb
kann man sagen als wir 2005 hat sich
bundeskanzlerin wurde waren die ausgaben
für forschung und entwicklung lagen bei
2,4 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
heute sind wir bei 3,05 prozent wir
haben deutliche planungssicherheit für
die zwanziger jahre durch pakte für
forschungs wissenschafts packte
exzellenz strategie und vieles andere
mehr und morgen das
dem einen oder anderen sehr abstrakt
erscheinen aber das hat etwas mit
unserem wohlstand und mit unserem leben
zu tun und das haben wir in einer
pandemie erlebt der erste bisher bis
heute zuverlässigste tests zum nachweis
des virus wurde bereits zu beginn der
pandemie in deutschland in der charité
in berlin entwickelt und einer der
überaus wirkungsvollen m rna impfstoff
gegen das virus wurde auch in
deutschland entwickelt auch dank
langjähriger zielgerichteter
forschungsförderung und nebenbei gesagt
natürlich war und ist niemand von uns
beim impfen in irgendeiner form ein
versuchskaninchen niemand weder olaf
scholz
denn jede
in jeder der in deutschland seit ende
dezember letzten jahres wurde bekam
einen impfstoff der aller notwendigen
phasen der klinischen prüfung und
notwendigen zulassungsverfahren
durchlaufen hat wir sind uns doch alle
einig dass noch viel mehr menschen davon
überzeugt werden müssen geimpft zu
werden doch wenn wir die menschen davon
überzeugen wollen dann hat das mit
argumenten zu geschehen und nicht mit
zurückhaltend formuliert schiefen
bildern von versuchs kann
was also sind die argumente für das
impfen wirkt man schützt sich und die
liebsten
impfen bringt uns die freiheit zurück
und je mehr menschen geimpft sind umso
kleiner ist die gefahr dass sich neue
mutationen bilden gegen die impfstoffe
nicht mehr wirken und aus diesem grunde
möchte ich auch von dieser stelle heute
noch einmal alle die noch nicht geimpft
sind bitten lassen sie sich impfen sie
leisten damit für sich und unsere
gesamte gesellschaft einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag den weg aus dieser von
dimitri
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
alle wissen diese pandemie war
wahrscheinlich der schwerste
eingriff in unser gesellschaftliches
leben seit gründung der bundesrepublik
deutschland und es war gut dass wir
wegen solider haushaltspolitik in der
lage waren an einer solchen
außergewöhnlichen situation sowohl im
innern das größte konjunkturpaket
auflegen zu können dass es jemals gab in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland als auch in europa mit dem
wiederaufbau von in dieser ganz
speziellen situation einen neuen weg zu
beschreiten und europa auch gut aus
dieser krise zu führen und das heute die
zahl der kurzarbeiter wieder unter einer
million liegt dass die arbeitslosigkeit
deutlich unter 2 5 millionen
2005 war sie fünf millionen heute die
hälfte das ist solide haushaltspolitik
und richtigen entscheidungen ab anime zu
verdanken auf die große koalition dann
stolz
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in
weniger als drei wochen ist
bundestagswahl
sie ist eine besondere wahl nicht nur
weil sich erstmals seit 1949 kein
amtierender bundeskanzler
beziehungsweise bundeskanzlerin um die
wiederwahl bewirbt
sondern es ist auch eine besondere wahl
weil es in schwierigsten zeiten eine
richtungsentscheidung für unser land ist
und es ist nicht egal wer dieses land
regiert die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben in wenigen tagen die wahl
entweder eine regierung die mit spd und
grünen die unterstützung der linkspartei
in kauf nimmt zumindest sie nicht
ausschließt oder
[Applaus]
ich sage ja sagt er nur die wahrheit
zumindest nicht aus nicht
eine von cdu und csu und armin laschet
als bundeskanzler geführte
bundesregierung eine bundesregierung die
mit maß und mitte unser land in die
zukunft
darin geht es wahrlich nicht allein um
die außenpolitik die nato und europa
meine güte was für eine aufregung ich
bin seit 30 jahren über 30 jahre
mitglied dieses deutschen bundestags und
ich weiß nicht wo wenn nicht hier solche
fragen diskutiert werden müssen das ist
die herz aber der demokratie und der
sitz in hamburg diskutiert
und bei dieser richtung
selbstbescheidung dieses wahrlich nicht
allein um die außenpolitik die nato und
europa das auch aber eben nicht allein
sondern es geht auch um handfeste
wirtschaftspolitische und
steuerpolitischer entscheidungen die die
zukunft dieses landes bestimmen werden
die zahl der arbeitsplätze und unserem
gemeinsamen wohlstand und deshalb meine
damen und herren
der beste weg die unser land ist eine
cdu csu geführten bundesregierung mit
armin laschet als bundeskanzler denn
seine regierung
verlässlichkeit maß und mitte stehen und
das ist genau das was deutschland
greifen
[Applaus]